old American now the university is under
the Marxist ideology right yeah so is
that true I mean when I went to college
it was where did you go I went to the
University of California at Santa
Barbara oh wow it's got to be no it's
not very woke
it was just a lot of like parties yeah
so you didn't study very much
no not really okay yeah did you study uh
psychology it's like that's a real
science kind of right
yeah
you see that I studied on
science okay no psychologists
yeah yeah exactly yes yes no no no but
psychology I think was very helpful for
it's not science in terms of like math
but it's very helpful in terms of like
understanding maybe why I behave a
certain way why other people behave a
certain way and that allows you to
operate in the world gives you an
advantage with that you know like
sometimes somebody's mean to you and it
has nothing to do with you it's what
they're going through right exactly that
kind of thing yeah yeah you know so um
why did we get into oh yeah I didn't
feel like there was this like Marxist
ideology but then again I went to
college so long ago that maybe
has changed clearly I think there is
there is like some I guess there isn't I
get how would people say like an issue
with wokeness yeah but uh I also feel
like sometimes that is you know how like
the right and the left in America need
enemies so that they have something to
talk about every day so I feel like they
just select their enemies
China is the enemy why was you fighting
against each other yeah yeah stupid yeah
yeah I really don't understand why they
do that well why do you think maybe it's
easier if we fight wokeness than fight
China because we know we're not going to
do anything about China we know we want
to get our clothing made you
know we want our furniture we want our
cheap stuff to buy on Amazon so we're
not going to really do anything about
China so why even bother to talk about
it you know they got the Spy balloons
going all over the place what are we
gonna do are we gonna bomb them if we're
not gonna bomb them
then maybe there's no reason to complain
yeah China is much more dangerous than
wokeness that's true but then walk
ideology
Chinese threat
s attracting us yes the real enemies no
way man the real enemy is not capitalism
yes the real enemy is a dictatorships
that is Marxist like totalitarian
ideology yeah that is really a danger to
humanity yes but the work ideas keep
distracting us to make us to believe
that somehow that American Constitution
is a racist right Market is a problem
the capitalism is a problem yes I mean
the professor economy say the all the
problems that we have the only solution
today is a Communist Revolution
you're a professor at Columbia said that
yeah wow yeah yeah so I mean that's
these people go wrong like I mean work
for Twitter Facebook I mean yeah I mean
all the banks and big institutions they
become President Obama and Colombia
right yeah like they get brainwashed
this way and then how do we trust people
to make the right decision but they get
certain biases that is so dangerous
um and you're saying that those biases
that they'll develop and learn will then
infiltrate our overall ideology that's
your
concerns take care send me message
saying that is binary
none I don't know but he they said they
do such a good job teaching him about
equity
can never be the same I mean we work for
the same thing right like we're
different yeah yeah but they teaching
these young kids who's two years or
three years old little toddlers they
teach them about Marxist ideology yeah
it sounds extreme when it's put like
that because I don't think anybody's
teaching a kid Marxism and they're like
hey let's talk about Mark but they're
teaching things that exist and are
promoted within Marxism like I have a
friend of mine who his kid uh he gave
like two pieces of candy to one of his
his daughter and then gave one to his
son and then the kid goes wait what's
going on I want my other piece and he
goes why he goes because it should be
fair and equal everything needs to be
fair and equal and fair and equal is a
good principle to teach children but the
idea that they felt like they could
demand it and it was it was their right
to have it
sure yeah you deserve free health care
you deserve free education yeah you
deserve Free Housing yeah like universe
is an income right in North Korea they
promise everything free and nothing
became free they did not give us
anything so in America these young kids
like she is Health Care is a human
rights we should make it free so you're
saying these are all good ideas but
you've seen them actually put into
practice and it never lives up to the
idea why
why feed their family and themselves
like why they should do anything for
free like how can anything be free in
the world
right like three songs I mean do we get
that cup for free like how do we make
that for free you did this podcast for
free
that's right but I'm trying to sell the
books
I try to wake up people's minds so I
don't okay if America goes down the only
option left for me to escape to Moon
without Elon Musk so he does not know me
I don't think my mood is going to be
strict Mars is going to be strict that's
gonna be totalitarian there's not gonna
allow you to have freedom information
they have to bear the nation they have
no time to be like walk but can you
imagine how how strict it would be up
there it's not even look it's like I've
been into North Korea I can imagine it
it would literally be North Korea it
would be North Korea but with food
because you can't go outside yeah you
can't do anything you can't you do not
want to go to Mars what I'm trying to
say is you do not want to go to Mars
especially because everybody is
dependent on everyone else if you just
leave the door open everybody
diesel America
imagine the world without America I
would never want to be in it yeah I want
this country be in it this is a
background of Hope for entire Humanity
but do you really think that I I think a
lot of times what happened is like we
see this with children yeah and when
they see this with like teens we see the
kids in their 20s and then the second
they get responsibility yeah they
literally convert immediately I've seen
my friends who are lifelong liberals
lifelong liberals like their entire
lives I've known them their entire lives
yeah liberals liberals liberal their
wives liberals
this happened a couple weeks ago my
friend's kid came home from school and
said that he was gender fluid yeah the
kid is five years old
my kids even know the term gender fluid
my friend was like we're putting him in
Catholic School right we are doing that
immediately yeah we are sending it
immediately Catholic School of course
okay yeah now that is to me the free
market deciding yeah so you also have to
have faith in the free market absolutely
I do so the free market is going to go
the parents are going to start going
whoa whoa what are you teaching my kids
I'm taking my kids out of school then
the schools are going to start to go
what the is going on here why does
nobody want to be here oh maybe because
we're teaching children things that they
don't need to know at five years old
right yeah so if we do have that total
faith in the free market it should be
applied to education should be applied
to ideology you know what I mean like if
we really want freedom
we got to let people
get the information we have to let
people have Marxist information
absolutely they should be boxes I mean I
love them there is a that's a thing the
reason why I won the captain in
capitalism no masses drive like you look
at AOC and Bernie Sanders but in
socialism capitalists get executed ah so
you're saying there's much less
tolerance so I want to be in a country
where we all can coexist and keep
debating we try this better and finding
the truth that's the thing is because if
you have confidence in capitalism which
I do exactly it's going to win I'm not
the insecure like the Maxes are so
insecure they cannot tolerate people who
are conservative and free market
if you are so secure about your ideology
why are you not like afraid and like
forces think the way you do and why do
you think that is
because they
because like a comment is a lot about
passion
it's not about like logic you know
passionately you think there should be
Utopia where everybody's equal nobody's
suffering like we're all inshallah land
right yeah but in the what yeah
everywhere like just nobody's sick yeah
yeah he's the best but
um so I think this is a passionate like
ideology you gotta believe in it yeah
and also it doesn't teach you any
intolerance yeah right yes you cannot
call it to the capitalism yeah it is
almost a beautiful thing to commit
yourself to which is this idea that
we're going to help everyone and
everybody's going to get an even amount
and there aren't going to be people that
are oppressed or taken advantage of it I
have I have a lot of empathy for someone
who believes that they can make that a
reality 100 so far that's dangerous
that's how they pave the world to hell
that's what China with good intentions
the union did North Korea did yeah very
bad very dangerous and you have good
intentions and not very being very
stupid yeah yeah but you're saying that
there's a certain amount of realism that
we need to inject yeah and maybe that's
what's lost in the discourse now yeah is
that we we haven't been as realistic and
maybe we're too far away from you know
the uh The Perils
of humanity maybe we're too cushioned
from The Perils of humanity in America
where we don't even see it as a
Potential Threat I mean the same thing
happens with Cubans that come from Cuba
yeah when they go to Miami all of a
sudden they're much more conservative
because they a lot of people suggest
that they live through a socialist
regime yeah and so when they come to
America they're much more concerned
about something like that happening you
actually said something like this kind
of on uh on your Rogan which was it was
really interesting you said if you think
you are oppressed you're not oppressed
because if you're truly oppressed you
don't even know what that word is yeah
that word doesn't even exist and I think
times are so comfortable and amazing in
America relative to history that we are
looking for all these things because we
now that we have all of our basic needs
met we notice these things so they seem
like huge deals because we've most of us
haven't had to worry about food shelter
clothing Etc so now we start looking at
these other things because we still
don't feel whole yeah and maybe that's
what Christianity maybe but as as a
mother yeah
I know you said you're grateful that you
were born in North Korea so you can
appreciate everything that you have now
yeah you have perspective yeah
as a mother
I can't fathom that you want your kid to
understand that type of appreciation
does that make sense yeah I don't want
him to go through the same thing that I
did yeah you're like perspective
humans are unique that we have a
capability to understand that it's
abstract of course like understanding
what I went through nursing is going to
be abstract to you you've never seen in
30. yes but we are capable of that
that's what we have a high intelligence
yes so my responsibility as a parent is
teaching Next Generation what I know
about the work right if we do that good
then what we know about the world they
understand from us then they find the
more things gotcha so that's like how I
see my response telling him not like
letting him go through the same
horseshare and starving every day right
punish him yeah but don't do that yeah
I'm like of course not but like I think
I he can understand that I think that's
why I believe in humanity I can teach
these people that what the actual
economism looks like this might be
getting too philosophical but the issue
becomes every generation that grows up
better becomes less passionate about
that thing your son will have an easier
life so he won't be as passionate with
your grandson granddaughter about or
grand non-binary about how life is good
you need to have perspective Etc and
then the next generation will be that
much less passionate passionate and so
it goes and that's actually a sign of
success yeah no because
[Laughter]
that progress is not something
automatically happens you need to fight
for it you know it's a you didn't
America didn't build out of thin air
people died for this country people
invented stuff they did not sleep and
work hard like so hard so somehow you
think if you just sit here being
comfortable and smoking weed and all day
and just watching Netflix and somehow
you're gonna get better as the time
passes no we can completely go backwards
yeah like I was watching the movie
Idiocracy yeah I was like this is this
is somehow wise bringing some burst to
me you know yeah so it can be truly real
thing North Korea is so well in the 60s
70s and then they went backwards and now
there's a cannibalism they're eating
each other is that desperate yeah